We've got a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime you want.
If it's 3:00 AM and you're rating the kitchen,
uh, and you want to call, you can do it.
And many people do.
Now here's an interesting voicemail that came
in last night in the wake of the New Hampshire
results, which argues there is something other
than Joe Biden being a centrist that's good
about Joe Biden not doing well.
Take a listen to this
David.
We should all be very happy of how Joe Biden
did yesterday in New Hampshire.
The fact that he is probably going to lose
now should make everyone very happy because
this stupid Ukraine story can't be used just
like Hilary's emails to make him lose.
Yeah, that that is interesting, which is we
know that if Biden is the nominee, it's going
to be about Barisma.
It's going to be about Hunter Biden.
It's going to be about all of those things
and it's certainly true that if Joe Biden
is not the nominee, it takes those issues
completely off the table, which we know are
going to be fodder for Republicans and for
Donald Trump.
If Joe Biden were to be the nominee and now
we also have to understand either way, they
will come up with something.
There will be a Hillary's emails, Hunter,
Joe Biden Barisma.
They will come up with something, no matter
who the nominee is, is if it's Pete boot edge
edge, they are going to come up with stuff.
If it's Bernie Sanders, they are going to
come up with stuff.
If it's Michael Bloomberg, wow.
They're absolutely going to come up with stuff.
So while I agree that it's good that the Hunter
Joe Biden Barisma stuff not become a distraction
in the general election that allows Donald
Trump to continue bamboozling people and deceiving
and lying and all of that stuff that he does,
that's good.
They're going to come up with something else
and we're going to have to fight it one way
or the other.
It'll just be something different.
But I do think that the color is right.
On today's bonus show, we're going to talk
about how there are proposals to ban fracking
at the state level in a number of different
States and in a of States it will have no
negative repercussions for Democrats in the
Senate and in the habits.
But there are some States in which fracking
bands may actually hurt Democrats in some
States, and we're going to talk about which
those are and whether that's a reason not
to do it.
I think you probably can guess where I fall
on that.
Also, just the small, it has again been indicted
in Chicago over last years, false, fake, fraudulent
hate crime claims that were actually a staged
hate crime.
We are going to talk about how it has all
unfolded, uh, next steps there.
And then lastly, again, Donald Trump is calling
to end the student loan forgiveness program
in his budget.
We talked a little bit about Trump's new budget,
which is a total fantasy.
Earlier this week on the bonus show, we are
going to dig in more specifically now into
student loan forgiveness.
We're going to talk about the economic impact
of something like student loan forgiveness,
how much it would cost, how Bernie would do
it, and so much more.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
Instant access is available to you at the
click of a button at the top of your mobile
phone screen.
Simply grab a membership@joinpacman.com coupon
code is available, uh, 2020 now it'll save
you 66% beautiful.
You can also get access to the bonus show
by making a pledge at patrion.com/david Pakman
show at the $5 or greater level.
I will speak to you then and otherwise on
tomorrow's program.
Crystal ball will be
joining me tomorrow and we will do an analysis
of what seems to be a possible contested democratic
convention.
We'll begin detailed to that and [inaudible]
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].